[Aplausos]
eu queria começar minha apresentação
mostrando pra vocês uma foto sua foto no
fundo de tela do meu celular
aproximadamente uns dois meses e meio
essa é a gabi minha filha e aquele no
desenho sou eu na versão dela um pouco
mais magro mas sou eu pra gente e pediu
que ela fizesse esse desenho assim que
soube da possibilidade está participando
aqui do telex e hoje estou aqui para
falar sobre como o direcionamento do seu
foco pode mudar sua realidade
mas como nem tudo são flores
um pouco antes de ela fazer eu tirei
essa foto estava um almoçando com ela eu
senti que ela estava um pouco preocupada
ela estava em semana de provas mas eu
não achei que essa preocupação tivesse
alguma relação com isso mesmo porque a
gente tinha estudado um pouco de manhã
ela estava super bem na matéria
falei filho está tudo bem está
precisando de alguma coisa está sentindo
alguma coisa falou papai tornou sentindo
um pouco de enjôo
eu queria ir para a escola hoje 11 não
filho acha que tivesse alguma coisa que
ela tivesse comido no café da manhã
porém não filha eu pego um remédio você
toma e você vai pra escola porque se tem
prova hoje não pode perder o pai eu não
estou me sentindo muito bem
eu queria ficar em casa hoje
de repente do nada do nada ela começou a
chorar chorar chorar chorar chorar ela
sai da cadeira onde ela está sentada e
pula no meu colo e quando ela pula no
colo ela me dá um abraço tão apertado
que eu sinto suor das mãos unhas dela
nas minhas costas
aquele choro começou a ficar mais forte
ela começou a soluçar a respiração
ofegante e comecei a ficar preocupado eu
falei calma gabi calma não precisa se
preocupar você não vai para a escola
hoje
depois você faz a prova ela foi
acalmando aos poucos
aquele dia ficou muito marcado para mim
porque minha filha de apenas oito anos
de idade tinha apresentado sintomas de
ansiedade assim como minha filha muitas
pessoas passam por um momento de pressão
de stress de preocupação e frustração
não só no trabalho como na escola na
faculdade e no próprio convívio familiar
o problema é que grande parte dessas
pessoas não conseguem não sabe lidar com
essa sobrecarga de informações de
tarefas de emoções e acaba está
analisando isso sem o controle do seu
comportamento
uma das causas de tudo isso é que talvez
sua atenção esteja sendo direcionada
para alguns aspectos negativos da sua
vida fazendo com que você perceba a
realidade de uma forma distorcida e
logicamente influenciam no seu
comportamento mas existe algo que está
no controle de tudo isso e se algo se
chama cérebro
essa máquina maravilhosa que você
carrega consigo dotada de dois sistemas
distintos e que funcionam paralelamente
aliás esse conceito de duplo sistema
cerebral foi trazido a debate público
pela primeira vez por daniel kahneman na
cerimônia de entrega do prêmio nobel de
2002 e quais são esses sistemas o
primeiro é um sistema controlado
responsável pelo nosso raciocínio pelo
nosso auto controle pelo nosso
planejamento porém se cansa muito
facilmente poderia ficar sobrecarregado
fica difícil você agir de forma racional
ou mesmo existe aquela tentação
por isso depois de um dia inteiro de
trabalho quando você chega em casa à
noite
você abre a geladeira fica difícil você
resistir àquele bolo de chocolate que
está lá ou aquela pizza
o segundo sistema é um sistema
automático
ele é responsável por fazer você
economizar energia para utilizar quando
e onde você quiser e como ele faz essa
economia de energia primeiro
automatizando suas ações rotineiras
transformando em hábitos e uma segunda
forma ele funciona como se fosse um
filtro
como assim um filtro imagina que neste
momento estão chegando milhares de
informações pelos seus cinco sentidos do
ambiente externo o que o cérebro faz de
forma automática ele filtra essas
informações trazendo para a sua
percepção que seja relevante pra você
porém descartando todo o resto ele
descarta mesmo de forma automática
isso me lembra até uma história que eu
estava dando carona pra minha mãe lembra
muito bem eu aqui dirigindo no volante
mamãe aqui do lado
o rádio ligado e ela falando sabe como é
mãe né fica falando falando fazia tempo
que a gente nós não nos víamos ela
falando falando perguntando como eu
estava comendo andré lógico que eu tô
como tá adriana sua esposa a minha neta
tudo bem mas ela falando mas eu estava
preocupado com um projeto que eu que
tinha que fazer à época não estava dando
muita atenção para ela não é só
respondendo
de repente ela parou de falar ela para
de falar eu olho pro lado ela está
chorando a mãe que foi que aconteceu
aconteceu alguma coisa ela começou a
chorar realmente falou não desculpa
filho é que eu comecei a ouvir a música
eu fiquei emocionada
eu não tinha percebido a música que
estava tocando no rádio e quando ela me
falou eu percebi era roberto carlos ela
ama roberto casa funciona pelo completo
só nesse momento eu percebi porque
entendo o meu cérebro está filtrando
essa informação que não era relevante
pra mim naquele momento
só que pra ela assim que qualquer
conclusão qual é o resultado de tudo
isso nós não vivenciamos o mundo como
ele realmente é
nós vivenciamos uma versão simplificada
editada desse mundo e essa edição é
baseada nas nossas crenças vivências
experiências de vida
tudo que você viu sentiu e ouviu e
aprendeu desde a sua infância armazenado
aí vai fazer com que cada um de nós
vivenciei a realidade de uma forma
porque as experiências de vida são
únicas
mas então como eu posso influenciar essa
percepção automática da realidade
antes de tudo você tem que acreditar que
uma mudança é possível se você quer
mudar algo você tem que acreditar nessa
mudança porque se você nem acreditar
você não tá dando essa opção para seu
cérebro novas conexões não serão criadas
porque tudo aquilo que você não acredita
em tudo aquilo que você não tem
consciência que seja possível pra você
não será possível pra você
algo só se torna possível quando
conscientemente
você passa a acreditar que aquilo seja
possível a partir do momento que você
acredita nessa mudança
a sugestão que eu dou que você adote
diariamente o que eu chamo de
visualização direcionada e o que é isso
é uma espécie de ensaio de treino mental
onde você vai mostrar o seu cérebro de
forma consciente o que você quer pra
você e para sua vida e como você pode
fazer isso de duas formas a primeira é
colocando fotos e imagens em pontos
estratégicos para você como eu fiz no
caso da minha filha colocando a foto
dela no meu celular no fundo de tela
porque sempre que eu pegava o celular
eu sabia que aquele dia eu tinha algo a
trabalhar na minha apresentação
aquilo me mantenha focado em uma segunda
forma é simplesmente você visualizar
imaginar o que você quer o seu futuro
imaginar como você que está física e
emocionalmente aquele futuro fazendo uma
prova um concurso uma palestra como
fazia muito bem michael phelps que
durante a manhã e durante a noite ele
fechava os olhos e imaginava abraçada
perfeita a batida de pé perfeito a volta
perfeita na piscina ele treinava sua
mente para que quando aquele momento
chegasse soubesse que o que era pra
fazer porque isso funciona
primeiro porque o nosso cérebro não sabe
diferenciar o que é real eo imaginário
como assim se você imagina algo do seu
cérebro ele trata aquilo como se fosse
real e o segundo ponto é quando você
imagina ou visualiza algo mais você
visualiza se determinado comportamento
mais forte se torna as conexões neurais
e aí você está mostrando o seu cérebro
caminho que ele tem que tomar qualquer
um quando aquele algo chegar
existe uma forma de você potencializar
tudo isso utilizando uma técnica chamada
hipnose
essa técnica que estuda muito tempo que
inclusive me fez voltar aos bancos
acadêmicos
após 20 anos
pra quem sabe um dia descobrir uma forma
de fazer com que todas as pessoas
consigam utilizar essa ferramenta ao seu
favor
é muito difícil a gente conceitualizar
hipnose mas o primeiro falar pra vocês o
que não a hipnose hipnose não é nada
místico hipnose não é sono de hipnose
não é perda de controle e muito menos
perda de consciência
a hipnose influência de pais para filhos
para os filhos e isso influencia hipnose
hipnose é foco e concentração no momento
que você está assistindo a um filme e
aquele filme emociona e você passa a
chorar você está no estado de hipnose
porque o filme não é real
e você se envolve tanto naquilo que
aquilo passou a se tornar realidade
mudando inclusive suas emoções como diz
o meu professor alberto realizou a
hipnose é a utilização da linguagem para
mudar sua percepção da realidade
são vários estudos e casos que comprova
hipnose eu quero trazer para vocês
um estudo feito em 1997 porém reset
manhã ele é um sikh ator americano que
utilizou oito voluntários e o que ele
fez com esses oito voluntários ele vem
do todos eles
no primeiro momento ele fez com que eles
ouvissem uma gravação e o que dizia essa
gravação o homem ele não costuma falar
muito mas quando ele fala vale a pena
ouvir o que ele diz
essa gravação
o primeiro momento eles ouviram a
gravação
no segundo momento ele parou a gravação
e pediu que os voluntários somente
imaginarem
a frase num terceiro momento ele pilotos
ou todos eles e falou que a tocar
novamente a gravação só que era mentira
ele não colocou a gravação e todos os
voluntários afirmaram terem escutado a
frase perfeitamente uma alucinação
auditiva e medindo a atividade cerebral
ele pode concluir que inclusive no
momento em que eles estavam escutando
realmente a gravação e no momento que
eles estavam hipnose naquela alucinação
a atividade cerebral era idêntica
uma perfeita simulação da realidade
como disse hipnose está na minha vida
está na minha vida há muito tempo e
realizou shows e palestras mostrando ao
vivo por voluntários da platéia como
hipnose pode mudar sua realidade
em uma das minhas apresentações
aconteceu algo incrível
eu chamei alguns voluntários na platéia
e uma senhora que estava super
participando estava super hipnose também
eu tenho uma sugestão pra ela qual que
foi que ela iria sentir o cheiro
maravilhoso melhor cheiro da vida dela
naquele momento
logicamente o cheiro não existia mas é
ela hipnose ela ia sentir esse cheiro
durante a apresentação ela tava muito
legal eu passava sempre falei que sempre
que eu passasse perto ela sentir esse
cheiro então passava perto dela 9 vinha
cheirava e sentia realmente aquele
cheiro terminar o show eu vou para o
saguão cumprimentar as pessoas e
explicar um pouco sobre o que acontece
durante show eu vejo que quem vem falar
comigo
a senhora ela veio falar comigo falou
andré preciso falar com você pode falar
muito obrigada nunca tinha participado
dessa experiência da hipnose
muito obrigado pela o cheiro realmente
estava maravilhoso mas eu quero te
contar algo incrível falei pô de falar
até curioso andré
há dois anos eu fiz uma cirurgia no meu
nariz e há dois anos eu não senti cheiro
uma perfeita simulação da realidade
ela estava emocionada porque ela não
sentia mais cheiro e do palco ela passou
pela experiência novamente
percebeu então que se você realmente
direcionar seu foco de sua atenção
porque realmente importa para você
você pode sim mudar a percepção que você
tem da realidade a visualização
a direcionada e a hipnose
elas podem ajudar você
atingir seus objetivos como ajudar minha
filha
um dos momentos mais emocionantes da
minha vida
em outubro de 2015
estou eu no parque com ela ela aqui do
meu lado de onde ela vê uma montanha
russa
o papai vamos aquele brinquedo ela nunca
tinha ido na montanha-russa falei 'vamos
lógico primeira experiência fomos lá na
montanha russa chegou pegou a fila
enquanto a gente vai caminhando na fila
percebo que ela tá ficando preocupada
primeiro com os gritos das pessoas
enquanto estão no brinquedo
ela não conhecia e o pessoal se emociona
no brinquedo mas ela começou a se
incomodar com os gritos mas o principal
não era isso que a gente foi se
aproximando mas ainda aquele barulho do
carrinho final fui começou a incomodá lo
a quem cá creche
aquilo me incomodava demais minha filha
e ela cada vez que o carro chegava e
saía ela ficava mais incomodada é quem
chegou nossa vez vamos embarcar no
carrinho
papai não quero com medo
levamos filha você vai adorar não quero
toco medo
eu não forcei tirei ela da fila e
comecei a conversar vamos gabi você vai
gostar eu sabia que a experiência na
bola só que ela não conhecia
pegamos a fila novamente gritaria na
montanha-russa atacar que o carrinho
chegando e saindo
vamos embarcar
aí eu estou com medo não quero ir
eu vi que não ia adiantar ficar falando
mas de repente peguei minha filha fez em
casa em casa em casa e inventa peguei
que eu fiz peguei ao pois ela no final
do brinquedo foi com ela até o final do
brinquedo no final da montanha russa
porque porque lá ela podia ver as
pessoas saindo felizes alegres porque o
final as pessoas saem emocionadas e ela
começou a ver aquilo e eu percebi que
aquele medo que ela aquela angústia que
ela estava ficando começou a mudar a
feição dela começou a mudar
eu comecei a perceber isso em
determinado momento um visualização
direcionada e hipnose influência
ela realmente mudou aquela feição e
quando eu percebi que realmente ela tava
com mais confiança simplesmente fiquei
de joelhos e nos olhos dela
falei que confia no papai
você vai adorar pelo papai agora eu
quero ir
peguei ela fomos pra fila novamente
aquele barulho das pessoas anda montanha
russa num incómodo dava mas ela sabia
que aquele barulho agora ela por
felicidade eo cléa vou falar a verdade
pra vocês
acho que meu cérebro filtrou porque eu
nem percebi o resultado foi esse aí que
vocês podem ver
[Música]
o senhor
minha mãe
eu tô
[Música]
[Aplausos]